there are new warnings this morning
about a possible link between severe
lung disease and teenagers and each
cigarettes and vaping Minnesota is now
the third state where serious lung
injuries were reported in just the past
month CTM consumer investigative
correspondent and a Warner has been
looking into these east cigarette
concerns and I know there are a lot of
questions about these cases but what are
we learning so these for Minnesota cases
Tony involved 16 to 18 year old
teenagers who wound up at Children's
Minnesota the Children's Hospital there
I spoke with the chief medical officer
dr. Emily Chapman who told me about a
pattern of cases with a similar but
unusual path now these teens at first
had symptoms that suggested a viral or
bacterial infection but doctors
determined their lungs had actually
sustained some kind of acute injury and
then the lungs began to fail some of the
teenagers even had to be put on
ventilators to save their lives dr.
Chapman says her doctors cannot yet
identify a common factor like a
particular brand of e-cigarette a drug
or an oil but the State Department of
Health says use of both nicotine and
marijuana based products were reported
at least 22 similar cases have been
reported in Wisconsin Illinois and
Minnesota in the past month health
officials are still investigating these
cases and any possible connections and
the American vaping Association tells us
that with approximately 10 million
adults vaping nicotine each month
without major issue they say it appears
much more likely that the products
causing lung damage contain THC or
illegal drugs not nicotine but so far
nobody can really say for sure dr.
Chapman wants patients and families to
know if symptoms get worse or you or a
loved one is being treated for presumed
pneumonia that it's important to follow
up with your doctor and make sure you
tell them if you use e-cigarettes which
has been an issue with teenagers who may
not want to admit it no very hard and
we've also heard of teenagers who have
been asked do you use e-cigarettes and
they say no and then they're asked well
do you jool which of course is the you
know the gorilla in the market the Joule
product and then they say oh well yeah I
use Joule
so that there can be a disconnect now
again we're not saying that jewelle is
to blame for all of these but there is a
distinction in some teens minds between
each cigarette and jool are though you
know they don't even think they're the
same thing so yeah if you really have to
ask these kids yeah and your health
officials are looking for that common
factor we hope they find it yeah yeah
okay Anna thank you